le mariage le plus distrait de l'année
celui de juliette gréco michel piccoli
qui donc hier se sont unis autrement dit
michel piccoli vous avez accepté
d'épouser chez les blacks au vu des
dégâts qu vous avez accepté les poser
mais j'ai dit oui même s'il merde
comment avez vous fait avez vous réussi
ce tour de passe-passe pour éviter dix
ans la presse en général
d'abord on l'a voulu puis après on agit
comme comme il fallait at il dit
vous deviez vous mariez demain d'avant
nous marier demain après nous devons
nous marier aujourd'hui nous sommes
mariés et vous avez eu le mariage donc
que vous désiriez c'est à dire seulement
10 absolue ce qui est étonnant c'est
d'abord de vous retrouver ici à paris
nous pensions que vous étiez parti vers
de lointaines contrées où c'est
finalement on est de mieux cacher chez
soi vous partez comptanoo pour les
restes à prochainement de l'aco oui et
la séparation ne sera pas trop longue et
vient avec moi et bien avec moi et là il
a réussi à venir
ça me fait beaucoup de plaisir c'est un
pays que je ne connais pas c'est une
terre inconnue c'est un endroit inconnu
et je suis très heureuse de le faire des
découvertes à l'étude c'est pour ça que
je me suis mariée il ya quand même un
problème qui va se poser les données du
problème comment l'avez-vous résolu si
par exemple je déduire qu et en urss et
vous tourner un film à cent lieues de là
vient bien l'âge des réseaux lui j'ai
préféré aller est le sujet tenu à
expliquer les tourner un film
et vous pensez que de nombreuses années
durant vous allez pouvoir précisément
concilie de carrière n'ont pas tout le
temps si facilement mais on y arrivera
surmontable
on peut travailler chacun de notre côté
j'ai bricolé
on dit que vous êtes un garçon
excessivement discret que s'il vend
presque timide et vous avez voulu cacher
le plus longtemps disons
ce projet de mariage je n'ai pas voulu
cacher de projets de mariage j'ai
simplement voulu me marier avec juliette
tous les deux tout seul voilà mais rien
est à cacher et mais juste un petit
instant à cacher que faites-vous
maintenant mais j'ai réagi eux terminé
juste terminer un film avec luis bunuel
s'appelle belle de jour et vous allez
maintenant chercher je crois vos fini à
la sortie de l'école et au fait on va
chercher nos filles c'est une école pour
faire le dîner de mariage tient lieu ce
soir qui a vu ce soir avec un grand gars
de tout avec deux climats riera est
plein d'enfants